With so much attention given to the cast,
costumes, action and special effects of a
superhero blockbuster, movie fans have a hard
enough time taking in the movie as a whole.
That means it's almost impossible to catch
all of the tiny details, nods to the fans,
and comic book easter eggs slipped in by the
cast and crew.
But not anymore.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Hidden Details in
Superhero Movies.
Batman V Superman
When Zack Snyder announced that his Superman
sequel would pit the Man of Steel against
Batman, he did it with a speech pulled right
out of Frank Miller's famous comic, The Dark
Knight Returns.
The influences run deep, as the first trailers
for the Justice League lead-in showed Ben
Affleck's Batman lit up by lightning while
firing a grapple gun - perfectly recreating
the iconic cover art of the graphic novel.
After planting a nod to his previous comic
book movie, 300, in Man of Steel, Zack Snyder
went even bigger for the sequel.
The sequence involving Superman saving a Russian
rocket from an explosive launch shows the
numbers 003 on its side - flip them around,
and it's literally the biggest 300 easter
egg he could probably fit into the picture.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Audiences never find out exactly how Peter
Quill came to pick his own spaceship, but
the orange and blue Milano is destroyed and
completely rebuilt over the course of the
movie.
In case fans were wondering where the name
came from, director James Gunn has confirmed
that Quill named his ship after actress Alyssa
Milano - his childhood crush when he was whisked
away from Earth in 1988.
It isn't just 80s icons that get referenced
in Marvel's space team-up, but their Earthbound
heroes, too.
Even though Iron Man never makes an appearance
in the movie, one of his best lines does.
When the new Stark Tower is revealed in The
Avengers, Tony gives Pepper Potts "12% of
the credit."
It doesn't go over well, and it's the Guardians
of the Galaxy who actually explained why a
few years later.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
When the villain of the movie goes looking
to build a new body out of Vibranium, he finds
a massive batch aboard a beached transport
ship in Africa, called the Churchill.
The name isn't just a nod to the former Prime
Minister, but to Marvel mythology.
In the comics, it was Churchill who sent the
famous explorer Shackleton to find Vibranium
in the first place.
Making this one nod to the comics all but
the hardcore will miss.
Ant-Man
After Scott Lang loses his job at Baskin Robbins,
he heads home to the apartment he shares with
the rest of his gang.
The room is shown to be inside The Milgrom
Hotel - a name that carries serious weight
for comic fans.
The building is a clear nod to comic book
writer, artist, inker and editor Al Milgrom,
who lent his talents to a number of Marvel
titles before taking over as publisher, including
“The West Coast Avengers”.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
The movie version of Wolverine may be a different
one than comic fans are used to, but the crew
on the movie are obviously big fans of the
comic book Logan - and some of his most iconic
stories.
When Logan first wakes up in his 1970s apartment,
it's shown that his love for a brown and yellow
costume is because those are two of his favorite
colors, judging by the interior.
Fans can also spot samurai swords and a painting
of Mount Fuji - all a nod to his famous Japan
Saga storyline.
Deadpool
These days, Kevin Feige is best known as the
man in charge at Marvel Studios, but he didn't
start out building the MCU alone.
the producer cut his teeth on other comic
book adaptations like Daredevil, Blade Trinity,
The Punisher, and X-Men.
It earned him some fans in the crew of the
Deadpool movie, too - the pizza that Wade
Wilson eats in one of his first scenes is
delivered from Famous Feige's Pizzeria.
To confirm that Deadpool's solo movie would
officially be given an R-Rating, the studio
came up with an amazing way to make the announcement:
arrange an April Fool's Day PG-13 announcement
in an interview with Extra's Mario Lopez.
The host played along, getting killed by the
movie's star.
But it wasn't his only gag.
In the actual movie Ryan Reynold's hero can
be seen intently reading from Lopez's memoir,
"Just Between Us."
The worlds of Fox's X-Men and Marvel's Avengers
are completely divided, but that doesn't stop
a guy like Deadpool from referencing his MCU
friends.
The biggest example is the movie's final fight,
taking place on a massive, dry-docked aircraft
carrier.
But it's only in the final shots where audiences
can see that it's actually a heli-carrier,
but just different enough from the version
used by SHIELD in the Avengers movies.
Those are just a handful of details that prove
the people working behind the scenes are often
even bigger fans than the ones watching the
finish movies.
What are some of your favorite, easy-to-miss
easter eggs in superhero movies?
Let us know where to find them in the comments,
and remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one.